wann benutzt man in der deutschen
sprache eigentlich das präteritum also
das simple passt und wann das perfekt
wie ihr vielleicht wisst gibt es in der
deutschen sprache diese zwei
vergangenheits formen ich kann sagen ich
gegen das ist das präteritum und ich bin
gegangen das ist das perfekt es gibt
dafür eigentlich relativ klare regeln
und die möchten wir euch heute
vorstellen wir fokussieren uns dabei auf
das gesprochene deutsch und wir benutzen
dabei einige szenen aus unserem 100
werben video das wir am sonntag
herausgebracht haben falls ihr das noch
nicht gesehen habt das ganze video gibt
es hier oben und genau darin ist nämlich
diese frage aufgekommen wir haben euch
beide formen vorgestellt und dann immer
einen beispielsatz gezeigt und danach
kam die frage wann man nutzt man
eigentlich was und das wollen wir heute
beantworten los geht es wenn man anfängt
deutsch zu lernen wenn ihr vielleicht
schon mal einen kurs gemacht habt oder
vielleicht ein onlinekurs oder ein buch
durch gegangen seid dann ist das oft so
dass man als erstes das perfekt lernt
also zum beispiel ich bin gegangen ist
eine perfekt form die perfekt form so
lernt man das auch wird im gesprochenen
deutsch viel häufiger benutzt als die
präteritum form die ist zum beispiel ich
ging tatsächlich ist das so wenn ich
jetzt spreche dann würde ich sagen ich
bin gestern zum supermarkt gegangen ich
würde im gesprochenen deutsch nie sagen
ich ging gestern zum supermarkt dieses
präteritum das simple pass das ist im
deutschen er formell und man benutzt
dass auch er in der schriftlichen
sprache es gibt aber einige ausnahmen
und die werden wir euch jetzt vorstellen
in unserem 100 werbe video seht ihr
direkt am anfang die beiden meist
genutzten werben das sind sein
und haben und diese beiden werfen bilden
tatsächlich auch schon zwei ausnahmen
tatsächlich benutzt man haben und seien
eher im präteritum als imperfekt hier
zeige ich euch nochmal die szenen aus
unserem video
dani ist neu in berlin
sie war noch nie zuvor hier
ich habe angst vor spinnen
ich hatte schon immer angst vor spinnen
ich sage also dani war noch nie in
berlin
und ich hatte angst vor spinnen
tatsächlich würde ich das im
gesprochenen deutsch
meistens so benutzten ich würde immer
sagen gestern war ich im kino ich bin
ich würde nicht sagen ich bin gestern im
kino gewesen
es klingt nicht ganz falsch ist klingt
eigentlich völlig okay aber man benutzt
glaube ich eher das präteritum hier
genauso wie mit haben ich würde nicht
sagen ich habe eine erkältung gehabt ich
würde sagen ich hatte letzte woche eine
erkältung
manuel wollte schon immer seinen eigenen
podcast haben die zweite gruppe werben
bei der man in der vergangenheitsform
fast immer das präteritum und nicht das
perfekt benutzt sind die sogenannten
modal werden es gibt sechs module werden
im deutschen das sind sollen wollen
können müssen dürfen und mögen diese
werden könnt ihr euch merken denn bei
diesen werben benutzt man in der
vergangenheit eigentlich auch immer das
präteritum ich sage immer ich musste
gestern zum arzt gehen ich sage nicht
ich habe gewusst dass kind ganz
unnatürlich im deutschen ich sage auch
ich wollte gestern einkaufen gehen aber
der supermarkt war zu oder ich durfte
das haus nicht verlassen denn ich war in
cannes hier zeigen wir euch nochmal ein
paar beispiele aus unserem video vom
sonntag
emanuel muss immer kartoffeln essen
er musste heute schon dreimal in den
supermarkt gehen um neue kartoffel
produkte zu kaufen
janus sollte schon vor zwei wochen den
müll raus bringen doch er hat immer
weiter gespielt
michael kann keinen tag ohne kaffee
leben er hat schon einmal versucht einen
tag ohne kaffee zu leben aber er konnte
es mit
ihr könnt euch also schon mal
grundsätzlich merken im gesprochenen
deutsch benutzt man in der
vergangenheitsform eigentlich immer das
perfekt mit ausnahme dieser achte werben
die ich euch gerade vorgestellt habe das
sind haben und sein und die sechs modell
werben merkt euch also diese acht werben
und dann könnt ihr euch eigentlich im
gesprochenen deutsch schon sehr gut in
der vergangenheit und sehr natürlich in
der vergangenheitsform ausdrücken es
gibt noch ein paar ausnahmen und die
stelle ich euch jetzt vor
hoch emanuel findet eine kartoffel in
seiner kapuze und
jetzt hat er auch noch eine in seinem
schuh gefunden
ein verb bei dem man beides benutzen
kann ist das werk finden und da hängt es
tatsächlich vom kontext bzw der
bedeutung ab wenn ich physisch etwas
finde benutze ich das perfekt ich habe
meinen schlüssel endlich wiedergefunden
ich habe ihnen gefunden hier benutzt man
das perfekt wenn man finden aber benutzt
um seine meinung zu äußern dann benutzt
man das präteritum zb ich fand die
situation total nervig oder ich fand den
film wirklich nicht gut
in diesem fall benutzt man das
präteritum
wir machen eine kleine pause und nutzen
die um euch nochmal unsere app ceiling
vorzustellen sie längst eine app die ihr
für ios und android auf ihr handy laden
kennt und damit habt ihr quasi alle
werben in eurer hosentasche denn ihr
könnt damit die ganzen werben die 100
wichtigsten werben aber auch 2000
weitere werben jeden tag üben und ihr
bekommt darin zum beispiel ein ganzes
online-wörterbuch wo er alle werben und
auch alle anderen wörtern nachgucken
könnt übersetzen könnt ihr könnt die
regelmäßig wiederholen und unter anderem
gibt es dort auch einen
kommunikationstrainer mit dem ihr die
verschiedenen zeiten und
kommunikationsformen üben könnte bei
jeremy gibt es heute kein mittagessen
denn er muss programmieren
es gab bei sealink noch nie so viel zu
tun wie jetzt ein weiteres beispiel ist
das verb geben auch hier gibt es
unterschiedliche bedeutungen wenn ich
zum beispiel sagen ich habe janisch
meine schlüssel gegeben benutze ich das
perfekt wenn ich allerdings darüber
spreche dass etwas existiert oder nicht
existiert dann benutze ich das
präteritum ich sage zum beispiel leider
gab es keine tickets mehr für das
konzert zu allerletzt stelle ich euch
noch drei werben vor bei denen man
beides benutzt und beides eigentlich
gleich natürlich klingt und das sind
denken kennen und wissen ich kann zum
beispiel sagen hast du gewusst dass
janisch früher ein lkw-fahrer war und
ich antworte war das wusste ich nicht
hier habt ihr gerade gesehen perfekt und
präteritum direkt zusammen und beides
hört sich für mich für eine
muttersprachlerin natürlich an ich
konnte es kann sagen ich wusste das
nicht oder ich habe das nicht gewusst
genauso bei denkt ich kann sagen ich
habe gerade an dich gedacht oder ich
dachte gerade an dich in diesem fall
würde ich vielleicht eher das perfekt
benutzen aber beides ist im gesprochenen
deutsch gebräuchlich ja das war es auch
schon mit unserer kurzen zusammenfassung
wann man welche vergangenheitsform im
gesprochenen deutsch benutzt ich hoffe
das war interessant für euch und war
vielleicht eine gute
zusatzinformationen zu unserem 100
werben video und jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf eure weiteren fragen was habt ihr
noch für fragen vielleicht speziell zu
werben oder auch zu den kommunikationen
habt ihr da fragen an uns oder auch ganz
andere grammatik fragen schreibt sie
gerne hier in die kommentare und dann
machen wir vielleicht das nächste mal
ein video genau dazu viel spaß und bis
bald
hallo ich
nehme gerade ein video auf
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja das war ein kurzer gastauftritt von
janisch macht jetzt einen kaffee